Hallo guten Tag, mein Name ist Ekrem Özübalı, ich bin auf dieser Station als Arzt der Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen ein Analysegespräch durchführen. Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Am Anfang benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten, danach können wir weiterführen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Natalie Schulta.
Könnten Sie bitte Vor- und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Natalie, N-A-T-H-A-L-I-E.
Okay.
Und Schulta S-C-H-U-L-T-E. Am Ende E wie Emi.
Keine R?
Nur E.
Vielen Dank, Frau Schulta. Frau Schulta, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren, Frau Schulta?
Am ersten Tag des ... 65.
Ersten Tag, 65. Okay, super. Frau Schulta, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,65 Meter groß.
65, groß. Wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Schulta?
Ich bin 71,3 Kilo schwer.
Okay. Ich habe das natürlich. Frau Schulta, was für Sie so uns?
Herr Doktor, ich habe starke Bauchschmerzen. Deswegen bin ich hier.
Starke Bauchschmerzen. Wo genau sind die Schmerzen, Frau Schulta?
Hier oben. Unter, ja.
In der rechten Oberbauch.
Frau Schulta, seit wann haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Herr Doktor, ungefähr zwei Stunden. Seit ungefähr zwei Stunden.
Zwei Stunden? Ganz neu.
Aber stark?
Ja, sehr stark.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Können Sie mir bitte beschreiben, zum Beispiel auf einer Schmerzskala, wobei 0 kann Schmerzen, 10 sehr stark Schmerzen.
Entspricht? Und was würden Sie mir beschreiben, Ihre Schmerzen?
Ich würde 8 jeden, Herr Doktor. 8. Ja, das ist stark.
Können Sie mir bitte die Schmerzen, Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben, Frau Schulta? Wie ist Ihre Schmerzen?
Dumpf, brennend, stechend, siechend. Wie fühlen Sie sich?
Es ist für den Koli-Gard-Chef Herr Doktor.
Koli-Gard. Seit zwei Stunden.
Kann ich auch sagen, stechend.
Stechend, stechend. Okay.
Frau Schulta, sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Herr Doktor, eigentlich ganz plötzlich.
Ganz, ganz plötzlich. Plötzlich angefangen.
Okay. Frau Schulta, ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie die Schmerzen einigermaßen aushalten können oder zum Beispiel kann ich Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben, wenn Sie brauchen.
Ja, lieber Schmerzmittel Herr Doktor.
Frau Schulta, haben Sie gegen etwas Allergien, zum Beispiel Medikamente oder?
Nicht Medikamente, aber ich bin Allergien gegen Nickel.
Gegen Nickel? Haben Sie Nickel Allergien? Okay. Ich habe das notiert. Wie reagieren Sie auf Nickel? Wie beschreiben Sie?
Ich bekomme die Kreis und die gerötete Haut.
Gerötete Haut. Okay. Frau Schulta, ich rufe an die unsere Krankenschwester an und gebe Ihnen sofort ein Schmerzenmittel.
Herr Doktor, aber ich habe einen Schmerzenmittel angenommen, bevor ich hier gekommen bin.
Ja, okay. Vor einer Stunde vielleicht.
Welchen Schmerzenmittel haben Sie angenommen?
Paracetamol haben Sie angenommen.
Es hat Ihnen geholfen oder?
Weil es mir nicht geholfen hat, Herr Doktor.
Nicht geholfen, ja. Gar nicht geholfen. Sie haben nachher einen Schmerzmittel.
Vielleicht ein bisschen oder nicht konkret.
Okay. Frau Schulta, gibt es Schmerzenmittel, die Sie angenommen haben?
Herr Doktor, ich habe mit Butter Macrurenrötchen gegessen.
Besonders nach fertiges Essen.
Macrurenrötchen.
Ja, Macrurenrötchen mit Butter.
Seit wann haben Sie Macrurenrötchen gegessen?
Vor. Ja, ich habe vielleicht...
Gestern oder?
Gestern nein. Vor fünf Stunden habe ich das gegessen.
Vielleicht, oder vor vier Stunden.
Im Mittagessen habe ich es gegessen.
Gestern Mittagessen oder?
Nein, warum heute? Jetzt ist es Abend und ich habe im Mittag Pause gegessen.
Mahlzeit.
Okay, heute Mittagessen haben Sie Macrurenrötchen gegessen.
Gibt es jemanden, der das gleiche Essen gegessen hat mit Ihnen?
Ja, wir sind zusammen mit meinen Kollegen gegessen, aber niemand hat eine Beschwerde.
Ja, welche Beschwerde hat niemand.
Nur ich.
Okay, ich habe das notiert. Frau Schurter, sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder phasenweise?
Ich würde sagen, Sie kommen und gehen, Herr Doktor.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, es ist kolikartig.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, es sticht Bauchschmerzen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, es sticht kommende und gehende Schmerzen.
Okay. Frau Schurter, gibt es etwas, das Schmerzen versteckt oder das lindert?
Wie gesagt, wenn ich fettiges Essen gegessen habe, wird es schmerzen, Herr Doktor.
Fettiges Essen.
Ja.
Und gibt es auch bestimmte Linder?
Aber als Linderung oder als Linder, Linderdäferkörung habe ich nicht.
Okay. Ich habe das notiert. Frau Schurter, momentan haben Sie Fieber oder vor zwei Stunden?
Das habe ich nicht.
Wie fühlen Sie sich? Kein Fieber?
Ich bin nämlich schwach und müde.
Schwach und müde. Seit zwei Stunden oder?
Ja, besonders seit zwei Stunden.
Frau Schurter, vorher haben Sie schon ähnliche Beschwerden oder? Das war erstmals.
Eigentlich habe ich seit acht Wochen ähnliche Beschwerden.
Acht Wochen.
Aber waren Sie leichter als jetzige? Sie sind im Laufe der Zeit stärker geworden, Herr Doktor.
Seit acht Wochen habe ich ähnliche Beschwerden, aber das war ein bisschen leicht.
Leicht, aber im Laufe der Zeit, die Schmerzen sind schilmer geworden.
Schilmer geworden.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und ich habe das notiert.
Also Frau Schurter, haben Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden einmal schon Ihren Hausarzt besucht oder?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich habe nicht.
Nein.
Okay. Das ist erstmals.
Ja.
Okay. Frau Schurter, haben Sie Schutelfrost?
Nein.
Okay. Gut, sehr gut. Schilzen Sie.
Ja, es ist Tagshuhr in der Nacht.
Herr Doktor, ja.
Nein.
Okay. Frau Schurter, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihre Haut in der Leit in der letzte Zeit zum Beispiel eine Farbeveränderung, haben Sie das bemerkt? Solche Befunde.
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt, Herr Doktor.
Okay.
Aber vielleicht meine Leiterhaut. Meine Leiterhaut sieht ein bisschen komisch aus. Ist das normal? Ein bisschen wie gelb.
Wie gelb. Wie gelb. Wie gelb. Ich habe das notiert. Ja, können wir noch mehr weiterführen und dann können wir widersprechen.
Ich werde Ihren Körper untersuchen. Frau Schurter, haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrüche?
Ja, seit einer Woche habe ich Übelkeit, Herr Doktor.
Eine Woche Übelkeit. Erbrüche? Gibt es Erbrüche?
Heute Morgen musste ich zweimal erbrüchen.
Heute Morgen zweimal erbrüchen. Und wie ist das Erbrüchen?
Es gab Essensreste, Herr Doktor. Und es war gelblich. Aber es gab kein Blut, Gott sei Dank.
Gelblich und kein Blut. Essensreste?
Ja.
Kein Blut. Okay.
Haben Sie schon zweimal erbrüchen? Und dann? Haben Sie ein Problem beim Stuhlgang?
Beim Stuhlgang habe ich ein Problem. Aber es sieht auch ein bisschen komisch aus.
Wie sieht es aus?
Seit acht Wochen sieht es hellbraun aus. Nicht normal.
Das sieht hellbraun aus.
Ja, und ein bisschen dünner als sonst.
In der letzten Zeit noch mehr ein bisschen dünn.
Dünner, ja, dünner. Aber Gott sei Dank gab es auch kein Blut drin.
Okay, sehr gut. Gott sei Dank.
Zum Glück.
Blaue Schulter, zum Glück, ja. Gibt es Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ich habe keine Probleme. Aber auch mein Urin sieht komisch aus. Es ist dunkler als sonst.
Dunkler? Was meinen Sie dunkler? Wie Altbeer oder?
Kann sein, ja.
Tee oder?
Wie Tee, ja. Schwarz Tee.
Schwarz Tee.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde? Wann haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, die Bemerkung habe ich vielleicht seit Langem, aber ich habe gestern bemerkt.
Gestern?
Ich habe das gestern bemerkt.
Und wie viel Wasser trinken Sie täglich?
Ein Liter vielleicht.
Ein Liter?
Ja.
Gibt es noch etwas? Vielleicht Getränke oder Wasser?
Ja, ich trinke Getränke und auch Champagne und Alkohol nehme ich.
Viel Kaffee.
Ja, aber es ist sehr wichtig für Ihre Gesundheit, um täglich ca. mindestens 2 Liter Wasser trinken.
Sehr sehr wichtig. Ich empfehle Ihnen täglich mindestens 2 Liter Pure Wasser.
Ok, aber jetzt achte ich darauf, Herr Doktor. Danke für Ihre Entzündung.
Gerne, Frau Schulter. Frau Schulter, haben Sie momentan ein voller Gefühl oder Leerungen im Bauch bemerkt?
Schon, dort begonnen.
Dort begonnen? Ok. Frau Schulter, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, die gleichzeitig aufgetreten?
Was für Beschwerden, Herr Doktor? Ich habe viele Beschwerden. Muss das mehr sein?
Gibt es mehr?
Ich kann nicht gut schlafen, Herr Doktor. Ich habe Kaumatik, Kaffee, ich fühle mich schwach, müde. Mir geht es nicht gut, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich meine zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Herzrasen, Herzklopfen, Kopfschmerzen. Ja, auch müde, haben Sie schon gesagt. Und dauernd Schlafstörungen.
Ich bin verwirrt, Herr Doktor. Sie haben viele Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie noch Schlafstörungen?
Ja, ja. Wie gesagt, kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
Durch oder einschlafen?
Ich weiß nicht, eins oder zwei. Ich kann nicht gut schlafen. Ich kann nur diesen Punkt wissen.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht damit.
Brustschmerzen oder Engelgefühl?
Die Frage ist sehr wichtig. Haben Sie keine Brustschmerzen oder Engelgefühl?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Ok, ok. Sehr gut.
Frau Schutter, haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich leide an Schildrusenunterfunktionen.
Schildrusenunterfunktionen?
Ja, seit 10 Jahren. Und dagegen nehme ich Ertroxin.
Ertroxin, wie viel Milligramm nehmen Sie?
Das steht 100.
Täglich nur einmal?
Ja, ich muss nüchtern einnehmen.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Ich nehme auch Magnesium und Aspirin 100 Milligramm einmal täglich.
Ich nehme auch Venoroton, 30 Milligramm, zweimal pro Tag.
Frau Schutter, haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen außer Schildrusenunterfunktion?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Warum nehmen Sie Magnesium, Aspirin und Venoroton ein?
Ich habe manche Nachrichten gelesen.
Weil die Berichten, dass Aspirin und Venoroton meine Gefäße nützlich sind. Deswegen nehme ich.
Okay, verstehe. Aber gibt es noch eine ärztliche Ratung oder haben Sie zum Beispiel eine Diagnose?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Nein.
Wer empfiehlt Ihnen Venoroton-Tablet anzunehmen?
Mein Nachbar.
Nachbar.
Ja, hat er empfohlen.
Haben Sie keine bekannten Gefäßprobleme?
Nein.
Damit ich nicht bekomme, nehme ich.
Okay. Wie viel nehmen Sie Venoroton?
300 Milligramm, zweimal pro Tag.
Zweimal? Okay. Und Aspirin?
100 Milligramm.
Okay.
Frau Schurter, haben Sie in der Last im Ausland gereist?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Keine Reise? Okay. Sind Sie vollgeimpft, Frau Schurter?
Ja, ich bin geimpft.
Gegen Corona auch?
Ja.
Frau Schurter, rauchen Sie?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich rauche nie.
Nicht super. Gut zu hören. Nichts zu rauchen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol? Wie oft, wie viel?
Ja, ich trinke ein bis zwei Gläser Champagner. Eine Woche.
Eine Woche oder am Wochenende?
In einer Woche, egal. Am Wochenende oder am Tag.
Ich trinke ein bis zwei Gläser.
Okay, Frau Schurter. Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist ganz, ganz routine Frage.
Haben Sie einmal Drogen konsumiert?
Ich habe ein oder zweimal konsumiert.
Nein, ich lüge, Herr Doktor. Ich nehme auch jetzt Kiefer.
Cannabis.
Cannabis. Nur Cannabis ein oder zweimal?
Ein oder zweimal pro Monat.
Aber ich möchte nicht darüber sprechen.
Ja, natürlich. Aufgrund der Schweigepflicht werde ich Ihre Angaben mit niemandem teilen. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Okay, danke.
Eine Angebe.
Ich hoffe es, Herr Doktor.
Frau Schurter, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Aber sie haben manche Probleme.
Ja, natürlich.
Sie haben einiges heidliches Problemen. Mein Vater leidet an Bluthochdruck.
Ja.
Und meine Mutter ist Adipose und hat Zuckerkrankheit. Alterszucker.
Alterszucker. Beide sind unter Kontrolle. Ja?
Aber ich denke ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich bin ein Kind.
Ein Kind, okay. Frau Schurter, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Managierin meines Mannes.
Managierin.
Er ist Rechtsanwalt.
Ja. Okay, sehr gut. Ich habe das notiert. Ja, natürlich. Sind Sie verheiratet? Haben Sie Kinder?
Zwei Töchter haben wir.
Zwei Töchter. Sind Sie gesund?
Zum Glück sind Sie gesund.
Letzte Frage. Frau Schurter, ich vermute, dass Sie schon in den Wechseljahren sind. Aber ich würde gerne wissen, wann war das letzte Mal? Jede Periode.
Vielleicht vor zwölf Jahren, Herr Doktor. Zehn Jahre.
Zehn Jahre. Ja.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Frauenarzt oder Besuchlichkeiten, Frauenärztin, Regenmässige?
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich muss besuchen. Sie haben nicht gefragt, aber ich habe früher manche Operationen.
Ja, ja, Entschuldigung, ich habe das total vergessen.
Meine Geber, Mutter und Eileiter, Eierstorben wurden total entfernt.
Total entfernt? Ja. Seit wann?
Seit wann? Vor zehn Jahren.
Vor zehn Jahren. Entschuldigung, vor zwanzig Jahren.
Vor zwanzig Jahren. Ja, ein bisschen. Vor zehn Jahren.
Okay, okay, okay.
Herr Doktor, ich habe Schmerzen und trotz Ihrer Schmerzmittel habe ich noch Schmerzen. Bitte deilen Sie sich.
Ja, okay. Alles gut. Ich bin verwirrt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich sagen soll. Bitte.
Letzte Frage. Gibt es noch andere Operationen?
Nein, nur das.
Nur an Gebärmte entfernt. Alles gut. Frau Schrotter, ich habe mich mit meinen Fragen fertig. Haben Sie an mich Fragen?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich bitte nur eine Behandlung für meine Schmerzen. Eine Linderung für meine Schmerzen.
Ihre Schmerzmittel haben mir nicht geholfen wie Paracetamol.
Okay, okay. Ich werde Ihnen erstmal eine Köpfe untersuchen, durchführen und dann Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Gegebenenfalls einen Röntgenbauch und einen Bauchutra-Schal durchführen. Ja, so schnell wie möglich. Ich werde Ihnen ...
Danke. Ich warte.
Das war es, Frau Obersen.
Ring, ring.
Hallo.
Hallo. Ich bin Frau Müller. Ich rufe Ihnen aus dem Labor. Frau Keller. Frau Keller Kalium-Arzt 2,53 Millimol pro Liter.
Frau Keller. Doppel L.
Können Sie bitte diese Werte Ihren Oberarztin weiterleiten?
Ja, natürlich. Vielen Dank für die Information, Frau Müller.
Sehr gerne. Schönen Tag.
Vielen Dank.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag.
Es ist ein Schöner Tag.
Ich muss etwas mit dem Kind machen. Okay, bitte schön. Herr Özywala.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Ekrem Özywala. Ich komme aus der Türkei. Seit drei Jahren bin ich in Deutschland.
Bis jetzt habe ich B1, B2 und einen Fachschulprüfungskurs gemacht.
Ich habe etwa sieben Monate Hospitalisierung gemacht.
Ich möchte gerne wieder als Arzt in Deutschland bearbeiten.
Welchen Bereich haben Sie Hospitalisierung gemacht?
Ich habe drei Monate in der Gastroenterologie, drei Monate in der Urologie und einen Monat in der Allgemeinen
und einen Monat in der Allgemeinen.
Was ist das für ein System, das Sie in Deutschland haben?
Wir haben viele unterschiedliche Dinge gemacht.
Bei uns ist es ein bisschen... Wie soll ich sagen?
Ich kann es ein bisschen locker sagen.
Bei Ihnen ist das Gesundheitssystem sehr stark und begrenzt.
Bei uns ist es ein bisschen freier als das Gesundheitssystem.
Was meinen Sie freier?
Das Krankenkasseverhalten, gesetzliche Krankenversicherung, das Inhalt bei Ihnen ist sehr begrenzt.
Bei uns ist es ein bisschen freier als das Krankenversicherung.
Bei uns ist das Krankenversicherungssystem eine Stadt.
Wir haben ein städtisches Krankenversicherungssystem.
Aber bei Ihnen ist das Gesundheitsversicherungssystem privat.
In der Türkei gibt es keine private Krankenversicherung?
Meistens gehört das gesetzliche Krankenversicherungssystem an die staatliche Behörde.
Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Bevor ich meine Patienten vorstelle, habe ich etwas Wichtiges mit Ihnen mitgeteilt.
Gerade aus dem Labor Frau Müller habe ich mich angerufen.
Unsere Patienten, Frau Keller, haben eine Kaliumwerte von 2,53 Millimitern pro Liter.
Die Kaliumwerte sind deutlich erniedrigt und entschädigt an Hypokalämie.
Was ist die häufigste Ursache für Hypokalämie?
Die häufigste Ursache für Hypokalämie ist die Erbrechen und Diarrhea.
Die häufigste Ursache ist die Diuretik Einnahme.
Ja, ich habe es anders genutzt.
Deswegen ist die Diuretik Erbrechen, Diarrhea, Durchfall und Alkalose respiratorisch oder metabolisch.
Okay. Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Hypokalämie?
Am Anfang sind es Muskelschwäche und Krampf, Reflexabschwächung,
z.B. Opspation, Blasenlähmung,
und auch EKG-V-Filme und Supraventrikulär-Tachikade.
Aber die Prüfer möchten Kama-Filme hören.
Sie sagen nur Kama-Filme. Herz-Rythme-Störungen wie Kama-Filme.
Herz-Rythme-Störungen wie Kama-Filme.
Okay. Wie können Sie die Hypokalämie behandeln?
Bei der Schwereformen ist Parantheralcalynechlorid.
In der EKG gibt es eine neurologische Befundung.
Parantheralcalynechlorid.
Erbrechen. Zoltumat.
Was bedeutet bei Schwereformen?
Schwereformen bedeutet, dass der Patient eine neurologische Auffalle hat.
Mit Elektrokardiogramm befindet und auch so wie neurologisch befindet.
Bei Schwereformen bedeutet, dass der Kaliumwert unter 2,5 mmol pro Liter liegt.
Das bedeutet Schwereunfalle.
Schwereunfalle. Okay.
Entschuldigung bei meiner Note. Lieseweise.
Okay.
Okay. Was haben Sie noch für uns?
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin.
Es geht um Natalie Schulter.
61 Jahre alt.
Er war ein Jahr lang Patient.
Er wurde am 1.1.1965 geboren.
1.65 m groß und 71,3 kg.
Natalie Schulter stellte sich heute bei uns vor zwei Stunden plötzlich angefangenen.
Sie stellte sich vor, dass die Schmerzen kolikartig und stichend waren.
Laut Angaben der Patienten, die Schmerzen ganz plötzlich angefangen.
Deswegen hatte sie ein Paracetamol angenommen, aber das kann nicht geholfen.
Als Auslöser beschreibt sie seit gestern Abend, sie hatte einen Makrilenröhrchen gegessen.
Gestern Abend hat sie ein Makrilenröhrchen gegessen.
Nicht seit gestern.
Gestern.
Bedeutet, sie essen schon.
Ja, ja, ja. Ich verstehe.
Gestern hat sie einen Makrilenröhrchen gegessen mit ihrer Freundin.
Und zwei Stunden. Sie hatte eine Verstärkung über Bauchschmerzen.
Als Begleitsymptome klagt sie über Schwäche. Seit gestern total müde.
Sie hatte seit acht Wochen einiges Beschwerden, aber das war sehr leicht.
Und im Laufe der Zeit wurden die Beschwerden schlimmer.
Seit heute Morgen hatte sie zweimal einen Erbruschen.
Erbruschen sieht kälblich und esseneste aus, ohne Blut.
Seit acht Wochen sieht der Stuhlgang hellbraun aus.
In der letzten Zeit war der Stuhlgang etwas dunkler.
Dunkler?
Dunkler oder... Entschuldigung.
Der Stuhlgang war in der letzten Zeit etwas dünner.
Der Patient war etwas dünner.
Der Stuhl ist dünner?
Der Stuhl ist dünner.
Seit gestern ist der Rhein etwas dunkler als Alpia.
Bei der Veketativanamnese ergaben sich dauerhaft Gesortbrinnen und Schlafstörungen bis auf Veketativanamnese unauffällig.
Bei der Vorerkrankunganamnese erwähnte sie eine Hypatroide.
Seit zehn Jahren nimmt die Patientin regelmäßig Erdroxin, 100 Milligramm.
Milligramm oder Mikrogramm?
Mikrogramm.
Bei der Voroperationsanamnese, die bei ihr wurde, war sie total hysterisch.
Durchgeführt sie...
Was bedeutet total hysterisch?
Total hysterisch bedeutet bilateral adnexial ovarian, ayasthoka, aylaita, gebermuta und vaginale Kopfexzession.
Als Medikamentös erwähnte sie, gerade habe ich gesagt, gegen Hypatroide,
nimmt sie Erdroxin, 100 Mikrogramm, täglich morgen, Magnesiumtablet, unklare Dosis, nimmt sie,
und Aspirin, 100 Milligramm täglich, einmal, und Minurton, 300 Tablet, einmal täglich regelmäßig.
Sie nehmen diese Tablete an, aber ohne ertliche Rat.
Wie eine Kollege empfehle ich.
Eine Empfehlung von einer Kollegin oder Nachbarn.
Bei der Allergie anamnese erwähnte sie eine Nickelallergie.
Sie reagiert gegen Nickel, Erdem und Pyrrhythus.
In der letzten Zeit hatte sie keine Reisegesichten.
Sie ist voll geimpft, so wie gegen Corona.
Sie ist nicht Raucherin.
Sie...
Akkoholkonsum ist ein oder zwei Gläser Wein oder Champagner am Wochenende.
Drogenkonsum wurde ein oder zwei Mal pro Monat Cannabis, wurde behaft.
Wie oft braucht sie Cannabis?
Ein oder zwei Mal pro Monat.
Okay.
Sie ist nach dem Hysterektom in den Wechseljahren.
Sie besucht ihre Frau arztregelmäßig.
Sie hatte keine Probleme.
Sie war ein Arzt.
Sie hatte eine Arteriehypotonie.
Sie hatte Diabetes mellitus.
Sie hatte eine Adipositas.
Sie hatte keine Geschwister.
Sie gab sich eine Analyse.
Sie ist eine Männin bei dem Kanzler.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat zwei Töchter.
Als differential Diabetes...
Aufgrund der Analyse habe ich den Verdacht auf...
Entschuldigung, ich konnte nicht gut konzentrieren.
Was ist Ihr Verdacht Diagnose?
Ja, habe ich noch nicht gesagt.
Aufgrund der Analyse habe ich den Verdacht auf Kulidiasis.
Wegen rechtseitiger Oberbauchschmerzen, Überkeit, Erbrechen,
dunniger Stuhl, brauner Stuhl und dunkler Urin.
Was bedeutet, warum hat sie heile Stuhl oder dunkler Urin?
Was ist Ihr Ursache?
Was bedeutet das?
Es gibt eine Obstruktion, die in der Kohle ist gestaut.
Deswegen gibt es in der Darm keine Urinogen.
Deswegen gibt es keine Urinogen.
Der Stuhl steht ganz heil.
Warum ist der Urin dunkel?
Deswegen steht die Irratation an der ersten Stelle.
Natürlich ist in Urin keine Urinogen.
Aber wegen der Erbrüche, Überkeit und Unappetanz,
ist die Erbrüche sehr wenig.
Was erwarten wir bei Galenwegstau?
Was erhöht in Blut, wenn eine Galenwegstau vorhanden ist?
Der Cholesterol ist sehr hoch.
Wer hat dunkler Urin verursacht?
Normalerweise.
Wer hat Cholesterol?
Er erhöht Bilirubin.
Er erhöht Bilirubin und noch die Hydratation.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass man nicht viel Wasser trinkt.
Sie meinen, dass Bilirubin hoch ist.
Er erhöht Bilirubin für dunkler Urin.
Bilirubin, Direkt-Bilirubin und Indirekt-Bilirubin.
Bei der Blut-Akala-Fosforat und Gamma-Glutamint-Transpept.
Sehr hoch.
Sie sind alle Cholestase wert?
Ja.
Wer hat eine Differenzialdiagnose in Betracht?
Die Differenzialdiagnose kommt in Betracht an Akutpancreatitis und Akutkornelsyndrom.
Sie haben als Verdacht-Diagnose Cholelytiasis erwähnt.
Hab ich richtig gehört?
Was bedeutet Cholelytiasis?
Cholelytiasis bedeutet, dass in der Gallenblase oder in der Gallenwege ein Stein entsteht.
Wo hat dieser Patient einen Stein? Wo befindet sich der Stein bei diesem Stein?
Es gibt Staunensymptome wie dünne Stuhl und dunkler Urin.
Deswegen befindet sich der Stein in der Gallenwege.
Choledoktus.
Wenn der Patient diese Symptome hat, sage ich Cholelytiasis.
Cholelytiasis ist auch nicht falsch.
Aber Sie können diese Frage bekommen. Sie haben sehr gut antwortet.
Was sollen wir zum Beispiel, wenn ich diese Fälle vorbereite?
Ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt. Cholelystitis, Cholelytiasis, Choledoktus.
Das ist auch kein Fall Cholecystitis.
Das ist sehr selten bei Cholecystitis.
Hele Chutul oder dunkler Urin.
Das ist möglich natürlich.
Das ist sehr selten.
Cholelytiasis ist eine gemeinsame Diagnose. Sie können Cholelytiasis erwähnen.
Aber wenn Hele Chutul oder dunkler Urin vorhanden sind, können Sie Cholelytiasis nennen.
Das ist spezifisch.
Ich denke, bei der Note am Anfang Cholelytiasis geschrieben.
Dann Cholelytiasis korrigieren.
Auf der Note.
Wer?
Ich?
Nein, das ist die Situation.
Die Situation der Patientin verändert sich auf die Spielzeit.
Wenn es keine Hele Chutul oder dunkler Urin gibt, dann Cholelytiasis.
Denn Sie können die Erkennung nicht genau beachten.
Ich verstehe.
Aber wenn es eine Hele Chutul oder dunkler Urin gibt, dann muss man das nicht nennen.
Dann gibt es Cholelytiasis.
Dann Cholelytiasis.
Ich dachte Cholelytiasis.
Denn es gibt eine Hele Chutul.
Das ist ein Symptom.
Aber wenn es keine Hele Chutul gibt, dann ist es nur Rehteobobachsmer.
Aber das kann man nicht localisieren.
Cholecystit ist hier.
Was sagt das?
Sie können es nicht typisch spielen, ohne Off-Syriksion.
Ich habe das in Erfarung gelesen.
In Erfarung kann man Cholelytiasis nennen, wenn es eine Hele Chutul oder dunkler Urin gibt.
Wenn es keine Hele Chutul gibt, dann Cholelytiasis.
Ich sage das auch.
Wenn es eine Hele Chutul oder dunkler Urin gibt, dann muss man das nicht nennen.
Dann muss man Cholelytiasis nennen.
Oder wenn es eine Hele Chutul gibt, dann kann es nicht Cholecystit sein.
Danke, Büyükmü.
Büyükmü, ich möchte dich fragen, ob Cholelytiasis oder Cholelytiasis oder Cholelytiasis nennen.
Sollte es Cholelytiasis sein.
Okay, Cholelytiasis.
Es ist keine Cholelytiasis.
Okay, danke.
Welche Diagnostik müssen wir noch weiter machen?
Um die Verdachter-Nase zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Dann ein Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Bei der Blut-Labor, Cholestas, Enzyme, Akronfosforz, Askaramagul, Tamiltras, Peptas und Bilirubin.
Pankratische Enzyme, Lipas, Amylase und Herz-Enzyme.
Troponin T.
Elektrolytische Nieren und Lebewerte.
Gegenbeinfalt, Urinstatus und Stuhldiagnostik kontrollieren lassen.
Anschließend werde ich eine Sonographie gegeben, als ein CT veranlassen.
Und eine chirurgische Konzil werde ich anfordern.
Okay. Wie können Sie behandeln?
Ich würde gerne diese Patientstation aufnehmen.
Als Initial-Therapie würde ich gerne Physikalsophon, Elektrolytische Substitution, Nahrungskaren,
Nahrungskaren durchführen, so wie Analgetikum, Antipirotikum, Antispasmolythik verabreichen.
Warum geben Sie Antipirotikum? Hat der Patient Fieber?
Nein, der Patient hat kein Fieber.
Dann sagen Sie nicht.
Analgetikum und Antispasmolythikum verabreichen.
Antispasmolythikum oder Spasmolythikum?
Spasmolythikum, ja.
Antispasmolythik, Spasmolythikum.
Bei der Urologie sagen wir immer Antikollinareschik.
Zum Beispiel Buskopan. Antikollinareschik, Spasmolythik oder Antikollinareschik.
Und gegebenenfalls eine Antibiotikum-Therapie werden sollen.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Meinung, wie Gastroenterologie, Gastroenterologie oder Heroic diesen Fallen behandelt?
Ja, als erste Masse, die Gastroenterologie, erste Diagnose Methoden ist ERCP.
Was steht ERCP?
ERCP ist endoskopische Pancreatokollangiografie.
Endoskopische Retirograta?
Endoskopische Retirograta Pancreatokollangiographie.
Bei der ERCP sind es invasive Unterdrückmethode.
Bei der ERCP können die Kalmung und Bauchspeicheldunus beurteilen.
Dann wird ein dünner Schlauch durch den Mund bis zum dünnen Darm eingeführt.
Dann werden die Kalmungen und Bauchspeicheldürschen mit einer Kontrastmittel in die Röntgenbilder gemacht.
Dadurch können wir eine Veränderung beurteilen und eine Therapie veranstalten.
Er ist also eine Diagnose als Arthroptherapeutisch?
Ja, Diagnose als Arthroptherapeutisch.
Ich kann es euch empfehlen, Zytvan zu benutzen.
Wir machen normalerweise 18-10 Minuten.
Deswegen kann man sich etwas aufhören.
Man kann es sich aufhören.
Wenn man sich aufhört, ist es auch leicht, es zu üben.
Jetzt müssen wir das langsam erinnern.
Ich bin nicht auf die Zeit, 18 Minuten zu beenden.
Es wäre gut, wenn man bis zum Test 20-21 Minuten oder so endet.
Ich bin nicht auf die Zeit, um zu beenden.
Genau, ich bin auf die Zeit, um es zu beenden.
Ich versuche heute, Ekrem abzuhalten, um in 3-4 Minuten zu sein.
Aber die Kale ist nicht nötig.
Das ist ein Faktor, das vielleicht auch Florian spielen kann.
Das ist der Grund.
Ekrem kann es nicht mehr.
Es gibt viele Fragen, aber ich habe nicht so viele.
Ich habe es mir gut erkannt.
Es gibt viele Fragen.
Du bist jetzt eher der Master bei den Orden.
Du fragst die Fragen nicht so viel.
Das ist ein guter Anfang.
Danke.
Ich habe etwas nicht gesagt.
Ich habe es mit diesem Grund gesagt.
Das melde ich dir.
Guten Tag.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich meine Patientin vorstelle,
möchte ich Ihnen etwas Wichtiges erzählen.
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, dass ...
Kalium Spiegel von 2,7 mmol pro Liter hat. Dieser Wert ist deutlich erneuert und entspricht
Hypokalämie. Nun möchte ich über meine Patientenberichten, darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, bitte schön.
Hier ist der Direktor, Natalie Schulter. Sie ist 57 Jahre alt, geboren am 1.1.1963. Sie ist 1,65 m groß und wiegt 71 kg.
Sie kam heute zu uns wegen seit zwei Stunden bestehender starker Schmerzen im rechten Oberbauch.
Laut Aussage der Patientin sind die Schmerzen plötzlich, nachdem sie von M'Quel und Rölchen
aufgetreten. Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in der rechten Schulter aus Strahlen ausreichen.
Nach Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen kohligartig und stechen.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei 8 von 10 auf der NRS. Außerdem erwähnt sie, dass sie seit acht Wochen
ein bisschen Beschwerden hat, aber die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden sind.
Begleitend klagt sie über Übelkeit. Seit einer Woche erwischen sie seit heute Morgen
zweimal mit Speiserwüste und Galle. Darüber hinaus hat sie eine Woche wässrigen braunen
Stuhlgang sowie dunklen Urin. Vegetative anamnestisch ergaben sich Müdigkeit,
schmerzbedingte Insomnie und Inapetens. Ansonsten ist die vegetative Anamnese unauffällig.
In der Gynäkologischen Anamnese, oder, ja, in der Gynäkologischen Anamnese,
Operation, oder Gynäkologin, Anamnese, da müssen wir das auch sagen?
Operation, Operation.
Okay, ja, unauffällig. An auf Vorerkrankungen leidet sie seit zehn Jahren. Hypothyreose.
An Operationen ist eine transvaginale Hysterotomie vor zehn Jahren bekannt.
Der Patient nimmt L2Oc in 100 Mikrogramm, Magnesium, Aspirin 100 Milligramm und
Venorutin ein. Sie hat eine Nickelallergie, die sich durch Pyruritis und Eruthemäuse äußert.
Sie trinkt zwei Gläser, ein bis zwei Gläser Champagner pro Woche. Die Familienanamnese,
die Familienanamnese ergab, Entschuldigung, bei der Vater, ja, ergab eine Bluthochdruck bei
der Vater und Arterielle Hypertonie bei der Vater. Adipositas und Typ 2 Diabetes mellitus bei der Mutter bekannt.
Sozialanamnistisch ist die Managierin ihres Mannes verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Töchter,
ja, die Familienanamnese ergab, die Familienanamnese ergab, Arterielle Hypertonie bei der Vater,
Adipositas, Diabetes mellitus, Typ 2 bei der Mutter. Das ist genug, es ist nicht nötig, Bekannt zu sein.
Bekannt demen Sie es, ergebote ihn.
Ja, ich habe gehört.
Nach dem anamnestischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Koledokolithiasis.
Dafür sprechen die kollegartigen rechtseitigen Oberbauchschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in die rechte Schulter, dunkler Urin und hellbrauner Stuhl Übelkeit erbrechen.
Ja, Differenzialdiagnostik kommen akute Pancreatitis Ulcus ventriculii in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Anschließend werde ich die Vitalparameter überwachen und Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Dann werde ich die Blutpil, die Entsündungsparameter, die Labor und Nieren, die Cholestasenparameter, die Lipidprofil, die Amylase, die Lipase und die Herzensüme kontrollieren lassen.
Wenn Sie als Differenzialdiagnose Akutkoronarezentrum nicht genannt haben, dann benötigen Sie nicht Herzensüme zu nennen.
Aber EKG ist, weil es gut ist, aber Herzensüme kann ich entfernen.
Das ist nicht so falsch, aber vielleicht fragen Sie die Prüferinnen und Prüfer, warum sie eine Herzensüme nennen möchten.
Sie können einfach antworten. Ich habe nicht Akutkoronarezentrum als Differenzialdiagnose genannt, aber sie hat Oberbauchschmerzen, rechte seitliche Oberbauchschmerzen und Myokartinfarkt kann unter Bauchschmerzen verstecken.
Sie können es so erklären. Wenn Sie es erklären können, müssen Sie sich nicht für etwas für sich interessieren.
Ob es richtig oder falsch ist, kann man etwas sagen. Es ist nicht wichtig, ob es richtig oder falsch ist.
Kann man darüber sprechen? Es ist kein Problem.
Man denkt, dass man vor dem Test alles richtig sagen muss, alles richtig machen muss, alles falsch machen muss, das Doktor kann das auch falsch machen.
Aber wenn man es richtig sagt, kann man es nicht falsch machen.
Es ist nicht wichtig, ob man es richtig sagt oder falsch sagt.
Natürlich ist es wichtig, dass man alles falsch sagt.
Es kann ein schlechter Begabtrag sein, aber es ist nicht so wichtig.
Danke.
Des Weiteren werde ich solche Abdomen durchführen und ein chirurgisches Konzil anfordern.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, werde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Als Initialtherapie empfehle ich Flüssigkeit zuvor, Elektrolytsubstitution, Magenschon in der Ernährung, Nikotinkarenz, Alkoholkarenz sowie symptomatische Analgetik und Antimetik.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich das machen werde, aber das ist ein ErCP-Nahme.
In diesem Fall muss man die Reaktion anpassen, ob man es macht oder nicht.
Danke.
Danke, dass ihr das sehr gut vorgebracht habt.
Ich habe ein paar Dinge gesagt, die ich vorgebracht habe, aber es gibt auch Fehler, die möglich sind.
Es kann auch im Test sein, aber es ist nicht wichtig, dass es Fehler gibt.
Ich habe die Möglichkeit, dass ich mehr zu viel zu den Fehler gemacht habe.
Ich habe die Möglichkeit, dass ich mehr zu viel zu Fehler gemacht habe.
Aber es ist sehr schön, dass ihr das vorgebracht habt.
Danke.
Herr Kuhl, kann ich in diesem Patienten eine Schmerzmittel geben?
Du machst das in allen Patienten.
Du hast das sehr gut gemacht.
Wie ist meine Variation?
Der Patient hat es vor einer Stunde bekommen.
Der Patient hat immer noch Schmerzen.
Du musst noch eine Stunde geben.
Es ist ein anderer Grupp.
Ich habe hier Ibuprofen.
Ich habe hier Parasiton.
Ich habe den Patienten gesagt, dass er sehr stark ist.
Ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Ich habe die Frage, wieso ich das gefragt habe.
Welche Medikamente ich bekommen habe,
ob sie sich gut oder schlecht verursachen.
Ich werde die Frage beantworten, welche Medikamente ich geben kann.
Ob es Alergen gibt.
Wir haben in unseren Karten Alergen von Novalgin.
Ich kann es nicht geben, wenn es Alergen gibt.
Ich frage diese Fragen, um zu beantworten, welche Medikamente ich geben kann.
Und dann gebe ich Schmerzmittel.
Bekomme ich Schmerzen ohne Scherzen?
Nein, ich frage.
Ich sage, dass es sehr stark ist.
Der Patient sagt, dass es sehr stark ist.
Scherzen ohne Scherzen ist nicht gut.
Der Patient hat es schon ein paar Mal gesagt.
Er hat zuerst sehr stark gesagt.
Dann hat er zuerst gesagt, dass es sehr stark ist.
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass es sehr stark ist.
Das tut mir so, als ob ich es schwer hätte.
Können Sie mir sagen, wie stark Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala sind?
Wenn es ein leichter Schmerzen ist,
ist es sehr stark.
Er hat gesagt, dass es sehr stark ist.
Kann ich Ihnen sofort ein Schmerzmittel geben, wenn Sie möchten?
Dann gibt es Alergen.
Wenn ich eine andere Medikamente habe,
dann gebe ich Schmerzmittel.
Das ist wichtig, um die Schmerzen zu verstehen.
Das ist mir logisch.
Schmerzen ist nicht alles.
Das ist der Patient.
Der Patient kann 10 oder 5 sein.
Schmerzen ist nicht alles.
Das ist der Patient.
Das ist mein Schmerzmittel.
Aber das muss man ändern.
Das ist etwas, das in der eigenen Zeit ist.
Aber der Patient kann es sich an die 4 oder 5 Fragen beantworten.
Ich habe Schmerzen, seit gestern Abend Schmerzen,
ob ich Schmerzen habe, Rechseitege,
und ich habe einen Med-Brötchen gegessen,
dann habe ich Schmerzen, plötzlich, angefangen,
und dann kann ich es etwas bewegen.
So.
Jetzt, um es zu beenden,
sage ich die Fragen.
Die andere Gruppe beginnt mit 11.
Schauen Sie, das ist die Situation mit dem Gastrointestinal System.
Es gibt keine große Unterschiede,
wenn man die Fragen stellt.
Was war hier?
Die Fragen, die mit Schmerzen zu tun haben,
dann Übigkeit, Erbrechen, Stülgang, Vasalasen,
wenn es eine Symptome gibt,
dann werden wir sie intensiv machen.
Dann kommen wir zu der Vagatative Anamnese.
Nachschweiß, Kassschweiß, Fieber,
dann Apathit, Gewichtveränderung, Schlaf,
und Herz und Lungen.
Leidense und Brüsschenmerzen,
Engelgefühl, Lufnod oder Herzrasen.
Diese Fragen sind die selbe.
Die anderen sind die selbe.
Die Fragen sind immer so.
Wenn Sie eine Reaktion haben,
die Sie in diesem Patienten-Ausgabe stellen,
dann ist die Reaktion schwer.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Das ist das Wichtigste in der Gastrointestinal System.
Haben Sie noch andere Fragen?
Oder was Sie für eine Reaktion haben?
Was ist da?
Ich denke, das war das Down-Syndrom.
Kann es ein Kind haben?
Das war heute nicht so.
Das ist auch so.
Wenn Sie so etwas fragen,
kann es ein Kind haben?
Ja.
Warum fragt sie das?
Auf jeden Fall kann es ein Kind haben.
Aber ich empfehle Ihnen,
dass Ihre Schwester
mit einem Frauenarzt sprechen kann.
Das ist so.
Das ist ein Down-Syndrom.
Das ist ein Angriff,
dass Sie Kinder haben.
Das habe ich schon gesagt.
Natürlich gibt es eine Reaktion.
Das ist ein Angriff.
Das habe ich schon gesagt.
Natürlich kann es ein Baby haben.
Aber das muss ein Frauenarzt sprechen.
Das ist das.
Das kann so gesagt werden.
Oder wie mein Bruder
das Down-Syndrom
von meinen Kindern
für sich interessiert.
Da kann man auch
das Down-Syndrom sagen.
Hier kann man auch
das Genetik-Standard sagen.
Das ist nicht unbedingt,
dass Ihre Kinder
Down-Syndrom
können sein.
Down-Syndrom ist eine
superlässige
Das Down-Syndrom ist eine
genetische Veränderung.
Das ist eine Superlisse.
Das entsteht
superlässig.
Das ist eine
riesige Faktor,
die wir haben.
Das ist eine
gesellschaftliche
Faktor.
Das ist eine
genetische
Veränderung.
Das ist eine
scherze Veränderung.
genetische Veränderung.
Das ist eine
Damm-Syndrom ist eine Genetische Veränderung.
Das entstand meistens zu Färben, das ist rastlöserhaft.
Das bedeutet, dass ihre Kinder gleiche Risikofaktoren für Damm-Syndrom wie alle,
wie alle, eine Risikofaktoren haben.
Das war mein Ansatz.
Ich empfehle Ihnen, dass Sie im Krankenhaus nicht bleiben möchten.
Momentan haben Sie keine Schmerzen, weil wir Ihnen eine sehr starke Schmerzmittel gegeben haben.
Aber nach ein paar Stunden haben Sie wieder Schmerzen und Sie müssen wieder im Krankenhaus gehen.
Deswegen empfehle ich Ihnen auf jeden Fall im Krankenhaus zu bleiben,
um Ihre Krankheit zu verhindern.
Das war mein Ansatz.
Ich habe es hier gesagt.
Ich empfehle Ihnen, dass Sie im Krankenhaus nicht bleiben möchten.
Aber wir haben Ihnen einen starken Schmerzmittel gegeben.
Deswegen haben Sie weniger Schmerzen.
Aber nach ein paar Stunden werden Sie wieder schmerzen und Sie müssen wieder im Krankenhaus gehen.
Deswegen empfehle ich Ihnen, dass Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben,
um Ihre Krankheit zu verhindern.
Das war mein Ansatz.
Ich habe mir die Schmerzen vorgelegt.
Es ist 11 Uhr.
Vielen Dank an alle.
Die neue Gruppe beginnt.
Wenn Sie etwas mehr fragen wollen,
dann können Sie morgen wieder fragen.